The thing is, every successful person you know
has failed at what they love to do, before.
I've been unsuccessful in my career,
you just didn't know about it,
because I wasn't famous yet.
And I was trying to be famous!
I was trying to get a record deal for six years!
And I kept getting turned down.
Any successful person you know,
even though it seems like
everything just happened for them,
it usually was preceded by a bunch of failure.
Or at least a significant amount.
But the great ones aren't the ones that don't fail,
they're the ones that learn from their failure,
and they keep going.
And they're persistent, and they're tenacious.
And for me,
I was trying to get a record deal from 1998 to 2004.
And I got turned down by every major record label,
including the one I'm signed to now.
And for me that means that,
even when you hear no,
you have to keep going through all those no's,
until you get to yes.
And with learning something new,
I think, it's the same principle.
When I was younger, I didn't really know
that you could just get better at things.
Because I think we're so used to that idea that
you're talented at something,
and it's sort of fixed, you know?
The idea that, "oh, he's just a good singer," you know.
And even with singing, I've gotten better at singing.
as I've gotten older.
I wasn't singing in a way that was sustainable,
and I wasn't breathing right.
I wasn't doing a bunch of things correctly.
I realized that there was a ceiling that I couldn't crack through,
unless I actually studied,
and worked under a coach to get better.
And this idea that things are just fixed,
is proven not to be the case.
You can get better at things, you can grow.
And even people that are innately talented
still need to go beyond that basic talent
that they have and cultivate it.